المملكه والولايات المتحده تبلغان طرفي
صراع في السودان بانتهاكات لوقف اطلاق
النار وواشنطن تلوح بادوات لمنع ذلك
بعد هجوم كبير على فيروسيه انظمه الدفاع
الجوي تعلن اسقاط سياره فوق المنطقه
قاضي يحدد الخامس والعشرين بمارس 20 24
موعدا لبدء محاكمه ترامب في التهم
الجنائيه الموجهه اليك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشاط لاهم الانباء من
العربيه
جددت الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه تاكيد على اهميه اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان
واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه ان الشعب
السوداني بحاجه ماسه للمساعدات الانسانيه
وعوده الخدمات الاساسيه واوضحت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان المملكه والولايات المتحده
لاحظتا ان الطرفين في السودان لم يلتزم
بعدم السعي وراء مكاسب عسكريه قبل وقف
اطلاق النار واضافت ان المملكه والولايات
المتحده ابلغت طرفي صراع في السودان بوجود
انتهاكات لوقف اطلاق النار كما طالبت
السعوديه والولايات المتحده طرفي الصراع
في السودان بالالتزام باتفاق وقف النار
الخرجات الامريكيه قالت ان لديها ادوات
للتعامل مع انتهاء وقف اطلاق النار بسودان
ولن تتردد في استخدام تلك الادوات في
الوقت المناسب واوضح المتحدث باسم الوزاره
ماثيوبيلر ان واشنطن ومجموعه مراقبه
الهدنه بالسودان تناقش مزاعم انتهاك وقف
اطلاق النار
وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه هدد بمحاسبه
المنتهكين وفرض عقوبات عليهم محملا الجيش
والدعم السريع مسؤوليه تطبيق اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار في البلاد
اذا انتهك وقف اطلاق النار سنعرف وسنحاسب
المخالفين من خلال عقوبات نفرضها ووسائل
اخرى متاحه لنا لقد ظللنا الصعوبات للتوصل
الى وقف اطلاق النار هذا لكن مسؤوليه
تنفيذه تقع على عاتق القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع ان الحل
الدائم للصراع يتطلب اكثر من ذلك بكثير
اريد ان اوضح ان المدنيين في السودان يجب
ان يكونوا من يحددون مسار السودان للمضي
قدما
قال الامير العامل للامم المتحده ان مئات
المدنيين قتلوا منذ اندلاع الحرب في
السودان بينهم افراد من الامم المتحده
وبين عدد الفارين من السودان بلغ 250 الف
شخص مشيرا الى ان المستشفيات احتلت وهجمت
كما تعرضت مخازن الاغاثه للنهب على مستوى
هائل كما قال غوتيريشن اسعار السلع ارتفعت
بمقدار اربعه اضعاف
تابعه الحرب على الاوضاع الانسانيه بدات
تتجلى اكثر واكثر مع استمرار المعارك وهو
ما دفع العديد من المنظمات الدوليه الى دق
ناقوس الخطر مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين التي حذرت من ان عدد الذين
يلجاون الى تشاد هرب من السودان يتزايد
بسرعه كبيره دعت الى ضروره نقل الوافدين
الجدد الى تشاد الى اقرب مخيمات للاجئين
وبشكل عاجل خصوصا مع اقتراب موسم الامطار
بدورها حضرت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
من خطر وقوع كارثه تهدد سلامه اللاجئين
سودانيين في تشاد مع اقتراب موسم الامطار
اواخر شهر يونيو
بوتيره عاليه جدا
يتدفقون الى تشاد هذا حال اللاجئين
السودانيين الفارين غربا اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر رصدته هروب المدنيين
60 الى 90 الف لاجئ دخلوا تشاد
80 بالمئه منهم نساء واطفال
يتقدسون في مخيم مؤقت لا مناطق اكثر امانا
تستوعب اعدادهم
المطر ضيف ثقيل اخر يهددهم فالمناطق
الحدوديه تشهد سيولا غزيره
وديان قد تعيق وصول المساعدات المنتظره
وتنذر معها بكارثه انسانيه اكبر
[موسيقى]
الحربه الدايره في السودان اثرت على قطاع
عريض من الحرفيين في شرق دارفور اذ يعاني
الالاف من ضيق العيش وصعوبه الحصول على
الطعام وصحفي صالح ابو علامه رصد الوضع من
دارفور
مع كل يوم جديد تدخله الحرب المستمره في
السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع تهدد
المجاعه قطاعا واسعا من المجتمع السوداني
فقد مضى على الحرفيين وعمال البناء في
الضعين الغربيه السودان اكثر من شهر بدون
عمل وما زالت مخاوفهم مستمره من اطاله امد
الصراع ان احنا في نقابه البنين تاثر
الهرفيين في كل المجالات في كل الهرف في
هذه الحرب هذه الحرب العين ونسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يقف هذه الحرف ويحقن
الدماء من هذه المصيبه الورطه الذي وضعنا
فيه ما يفوق الخمسه مئات عامل بشرق دارفور
اليوم خرج دائره الانتاج من بينهم ابو
القاسم صالح علي الذي ياتي الى هذا المكان
يوميا يتبادل الاخبار مع رفقائه املين في
وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في السودان لتعود
الامور الى ما كانت عليه
تنظر الينا بان الرحمه
ساعد الناس
الناس مضرره يعني عماله واقف ما شغاله
الواحد لا يملك قوته
يعني الوجبه الواحده له اصابع والله
الهدنه هي كويسه يعني زائد حققت ونتمنى
تكون دائمه
انه الحرب عصر مع المواطن يعني والمواطن
ما له ذنبي في حته زي دي انت ماشيا مع
الاوضاع القاسيه يقوم الحرفيون يوميا
باعداد وجبه الافطار بدعم من الخيرين
يتشارك فيها الجميع على الها تسد رماقهم
وتخفف عنهم صعوبه الايام
ووطئت الحاجه ونحن لما شفنا بانه الناس دي
بتيجي من الصباح لغايه المساء مبتلقى حق
الفطور ما بتلقى حق الشاي ما بتلقى يعني
اي شيء يهو بدينا بالبليله دي كوجبه
وجبه لغايه الساعه 11 12 الواحد ان شاء
الله بتناولها كذا
ومستغرينا عليها كده في ظل الحرب التي
يعيشها السودان تزداد ويلاته المجتمع سوءا
لا سيما البطاله وانعدام الامن والغذاء
واقع قد لا ينتهي الا باسكات صوت البندقيه
في تطور جديد في الازمه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بالجراد الروسيه
المنتخبه لاوكرانيا ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي
اسقطت الطائره مسيره دون وقوع اصابات وقبل
ذلك اعلن حاكم المقاطعه سقوط عبوه الناسفه
على احد الطرق في المدينه في المركز
الاداري دون ان يصفر ذلك ايضا عن اصابات
بين السكان فيما تضررت سياره واحده
حاكموا مقاطعه كان اعلن الغاء نظام مكافحه
الارهاب في المقاطعه بعد يوم واحد من فرضه
على خلفيه التسلل مجموعه وصفها بالتخريبيه
الى داخل الروسي كما اكد حاكم مقاطعه
بيلغرود اجلاء نحو 100 شخص من بلدتي
في المقاطعه فيما اعلنت السلطات مقتل شخص
واصابه 13 جراء الهجوم الذي قيل بان
مجموعه اوكرانيه تخريبيه قامت
بتنفيذه
وقد شككت الولايات المتحده في صحه تقارير
تفيد باستخدام اسلحه امريكيه قدمت
لاوكرانيا في الهجوم على
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
نواشنطن لا تشجع على تنفيذ ضربات داخل
روسيا
هو في بقى اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تصفيه مجموعه مسلحه قالت انها توغلت الى
بيلو جرود من اوكرانيا قالت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيه جانا مليار ان الوضع في
المقاطعه هو ازمه داخليه روسيه واكدت ان
بلادها لا تخوض حروبا على اراض اجنبيه
بين هذه الصور وهذه تحول جديد في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتقاذف بالاتهامات بين
كييف وموسكو اتهامات بحقيقه واحده حتى
اللحظه حقيقه تقول ان المعركه عبرت الحدود
الاوكرانيه
بالقرود تحت النار
بعمق ثمانيه كيلومترات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه تتعرض مدينه
لهجمات قيل انها اوكرانيه الهجوم وفقا
للكرملين بدا بطائرات مسيره تبعه اقتحام
قوه عسكريه قالت انهم مجموعه من المخربين
امر دفع السلطات لاجل اء المدنيين من تسع
قرى حدوديه واعلان نظام مكافحه الارهاب
في اول تعليق روسي على التطورات الجديده
اتهم الكريم بالوقوف وراء الهجوم بهدف
تحويل الانتباه عن بخموت اتهام رفضته كييف
ونفت علاقتها بالهجوم وفقا للاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه فان الهجوم نفذته مجموعتان
روسيتان معارضتان الاولى تسمى فيلق حريه
روسيا والثانيه فيلق المتطوعين الروس وكلا
المجموعتين تتالفان من مواطنين روس اذ
اعلنت احدى المجموعتين تحرير بلده كوزينكا
الحدوديه مع ان الهجوم ليس الاول على
الاراضي الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكان قد سبقه هجوم على الكرمل
نفسه الا انه الاول الاقتحام وتوغل عسكري
داخل روسيا هجوم قد يفتح ابوابا جديده من
الحرب وتطوراتها
قوه
اعلن ان قوه هيباتا تسيطر تماما على مدينه
بخموت وتقوم عناصر قواته حاليا بتمشيط
شوارع المدينه
واوضح القائد روسيا الهدف من بخموت لا
يمكن لا يكمل في السيطره على المدينه
وانما القضاء على من كان يجب القضاء عليهم
كما قال
اكد باننا كما يتحدث عن مجموعه سنخرج من
مخموت لاعاده التهيئه والعلاج والتسلح بعد
427 يوما من القتال وان قوته ستسلم
مواقعها في بخموت بشكل منظم حتى الاول من
الشهر المقبل للقوات الروسيه قائد قوات
هاجمه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مجددا وقال
انها مجبره على تسلم المواقع وفي حال لم
تتمكن من هذا يجب الاعتراف بان باجنر
اصبحت على مستوى اعلى من وزاره الدفاع
اكد تقرير للاستخبارات الالمانيه للقدرات
العسكريه الروسيه لا تزال قادره على شان
حروب طويله الامد رغم الحرب الدائره في
اوكرانيا مؤكدا الا دلائل على ضعف بوتين
بعد 15 شهرا من القتال
شهاده المانيه تقييم استخباراتي
اشاد بقوه بوتين ونظامه وان نفسه لا يزال
طويلا
رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات يقول لا مؤشرات على
ضعف نظام بوتين ولا حتى تصدعات ملحوظه
بعد 15 شهرا على الحرب روسيا قادره علشان
حرب طويله
تقييم الماني سببه اعتماد روسيا على
التجنيد وايضا التسلح والذخيرات
تصريحات تزامنت مع تصدي روسيا لعمليات
اوكرانيه على الحدود
عمليات نفتها كييف سابقا
افصحت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن ارسال احدى
طائراتها الحربيه الاعتراض قاذفتين
امريكيتين فوق بحر البلطيق كانت تقتربان
من الحدود الروسيه وقالت وزاره الدفاع على
تيليجرام بعد انسحاب الطائرتين الحربيتين
الاجنبيتين من الحدود الروسيه عادت
المقاتله الروسيه الى قاعدتها الجويه من
دون اي حادث يذكر
عشره مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
في ازمه ديون الامريكيه شروط جمهوريين
تزيد الضغوط على بايدن وتحذيرات
بالنفاذ الاموال
اهلا بكم من جديد قال عمر بوليف رئيس وفد
المجلس الاعلى للدوله الليبيه في اجتماعات
6 + 6 المنعقده في المغرب ان اللجنه
تتوصلت الى توافق بخصوص انتخاب رئيس
الليبي ومجلس الامه مضيفا ان سلطه
التشريعيه الليبيه ستتشكل من مجلس نواب
ومجلس شيوخ
تذكر اللجنه المشتركه بان السلطه
التشريعيه القادمه
اي مجلس الامه
سيشكل من غرفتين
مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ وهو ما يستغرق
بعض الوقت في صياغه وضبط التشريعات الخاصه
بهما تحيط اللجنه المشتركه الراي العام
الوطني والدولي علما بان
حققت توافقا بخصوص النقاط المتعلقه
بانتخاب رئيس الدوله
واعضاء مجلس الامه
علاوه على كيفيه اشراك الاحزاب السياسيه
في انتخابات مجلس النواب عبر قوائم حزبيه
او ترشحات فرديه تؤكد اللجنه المشتركه حرص
اعضائها وحرص زملائهم في مجلسي النواب
والدوله على استكمال اعداد مشاريع
القوانين الانتخابيه المختلفه في هذا
اللقاء
بما يحقق التوصل الى اطار تشريعي توافقي
وشامل للانتخابات في ليبيا فان الواقع
الليبي الحالي يفرض علينا جميعا تغليب
مصلحه الوطن على كل الحسابات الضيقه وذلك
من خلال تعزيز الثقه المتبادله والاراده
السياسيه المشتركه
عبر تشكيل حكومه موحده
تمهد للاستحقاقات الانتخابيه في كل البلاد
وتتعامل معها بشكل مسؤول وشفاف
حدد قاضا في نيويورك تاريخ الخامس
والعشرين من مارس من العام المقبل موعدا
لبدء محاكمه الرئيس دونالد ترامب في تهامي
الموجهه اليه وابلغ القاضي اخوان مارشنت
ترامب بضروره التقيد بما يمكنه نشره عبر
الاعلام ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بشان
القضيه
ويتزامن موعد محاكمه الرئيس السابق مع
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري التي
يامل ترامب الفوز بها وخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقرره في نوفمبر 2021 في
مواجهه الرئيس الحالي الديمقراطي جو بايدن
الذي اخرجه من البيت الابيض في 2020
القاضي اوضح ان الامر الصادر لا يحرم
ترامب من التحدث عن القضيه ولا عن حملته
للانتخابات الرئاسيه 20 24
قال البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ورئيس مجلس النواب كيف متفقان على
ان التخلف عن سداد الدين امر غير مطروح
على طاوله النقاشات مشيرا الى وجود مجال
للاتفاق على السداد وشددت المتحدث باسم
البيت الابيض كارين جانبير على ان عواقب
التخلف عن سداد الديون لاول مره ستكون
وخيمه على الشعب والاقتصاد وكذا البيت
الابيض انه لا ينوي اللجوء الى الماده
الرابعه عشر في الدستور لرفع سقف الدين
بالقوه امام احتمال التخلف عن السداد
رغم فشل اجتماع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيسي مجلس النواب كيفن مكارتي بالتوصل
الى اتفاق حول سقف الدين التفاؤل موجود
الى طاوله التفاوض اكد انه ما يعملان على
التوصل الى حل وسط بشان الميزانيه قبل
الاول من يونيو
الجمهوريون القوا باللوم على الرئيس بايدن
واعاد اتهامه بالتاخر في اجراء المفاوضات
مع مكارتي واكدوا تمسكهم بشروطهم كما اوضح
زعيمهم في مجلس النواب
الذي رايناه في الايام القليله الماضيه من
جو بايدن هو الاستمرار في تضييع الوقت
وليس تقديم افكار جاده على طاوله
المفاوضات في الواقع تقديم افكار جديده
غير مالوفه الرئيس يتحدث عن زياده الضرائب
لقد اوضحنا منذ البدايه اننا لن نرفع
الضرائب
في المقابل اعتبر رئيس التجمع الديمقراطي
في مجلس النواب بيتر اجويلار ان
الجمهوريين محتجزون من قبل الجناح
المتطرفه في حزبهم
الديمقراطيون في مجلس النواب على
التخفيضات المدمره للمساعدات الغذائيه
للمعلمين او التخفيف يحتاج رئيس مجلس
النواب مكارثي الى ان يكون جادا الطرفان
متمسكان بشروطهما ويتبادلان التهمه حول
ازمه الدين الذي ارتفع من نحو خمسه
التريليونات دولار عام 2000 الى اكثر من
31 تريليون دولار هذا العام في جو باك اذا
عدت الى الفتره التي كان فيها الرئيس
كلينتون في منصبه ثم غادره فقد ترك في
الواقع فائضا بمئات ملايين الدولارات التي
اعدها جورج w بوش الى الاغنياء عبر
التخفيضات الضريبيه ثم بدات حرب العراق
وافغانستان بزياده العيش الى الرقم اليوم
وادى الركود عام 2008 الى تفاقم المشكله
ولعل الحل الوحيد المتبقي للازمه الحاليه
وفق خبراء هو رفع موجز لسقف الدين لفتره
زمنيه محدده لاعطاء مزيد من الوقت للطرفين
لمواصله العمل على القضيه يدور الحديث
الان في واشنطن على ان المشرعين قد يبقون
في العاصمه خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع
الطويله التي تتزامن مع عيد العمال من اجل
التوصل الى حل للازمه حسين الطوض العربيه
واشنطن
حصدت قناه العربيه ثمان وثلاثين جائزه من
بينها خمس جوائز من الفئه الذهبيه من
جوائز تلي التي تعنى بتكريم التميز في
مجال التلفزيون والفيديو
جوائز تيل العالميه الفئه الذهبيه البرامج
على خطى العرب مهمه خاصه
عسكريتاريه
التغطيات الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
تقرير بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو
بايدن
ثمان وثلاثون جائزه نصيب قناه العربيه من
جوائز تالي العالميه في نسختها الرابعه
والاربعين
الجائزه التي تنظم سنويا في الولايات
المتحده تقدم لارفع الانتاجات التلفزيونيه
وتقدم في فئات ثلاث
ذهبيه وفضيه مبرونسي
الجائزه تعد واحده من اهم الجوائز
المتخصصه في مجال تقييم محتوى الفيديو
والانتاج المرئي بمشاركه خبير من مؤسسه
اعلاميه وقنوات وشركات انتاج دوليه ضمن
الفئات التي ربحت جائزه التالي خمس جوائز
ذهبيه كانت من نصيبي ثلاثه برامج وتغطيتين
على الصعيد البرامج برنامج على خطى العرب
ومهمه خاصه وعسكري تاريا اما على الصعيد
التغطيه فكانت من نصيب تغطيه الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه وكذلك تقرير نفذ بتقنيه
واقع الافتراضي من هو
جوائز تالي التي حازتها قناه العربيه كانت
ضمنها 20 جائزه فضيه وثلاثه عشره جائزه من
الفئه البرونزيه
ذهبت لعدد من برامج العربيه وتغطياتها
الخاصه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والوثائقيه
وبرامجها على مواقع التواصل والتصميم
الابداعي واستخدام الواقع المعزز
تبارك لزملاء في العربيه هذا التميز وفي
الختام هذا تذكير بابرز ما جاء في العشره
من اخبار
المملكه والولايات المتحده تبلغان طرفي
صراع في السودان بانتهاكات لوقف النار
واشنطن تلوح بادوات لمنع ذلك
بعد هجوم كبير على
بيلجاروداروسيه انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسي
تعلن اسقاط مسيره فوق المنطقه
وقضنا في نيويورك يحدد الخامس والعشرين من
مارس 2020
موعدا لبدء محاكمه رئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب الجنائيه الموجه له
الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات